of equipment for healthcare workers here
at home
and today i'm shortly going to be
signing another executive order
they'll help address the vulnerabilities
in our supply chains across
additional critical sectors of our
economy
so the american people are prepared to
withstand any crisis
and rely on ourselves this is about
making sure the united states can meet
every challenge we face
in this new era pandemics but also in
defense
cyber security climate change and so
much more
and the best way to do that is by
protecting and and
sharpening america's competitive edge by
investing here at home as i've said from
the beginning while i was running
we're going to invest in america we're
going to invest in american workers
and then we can be much better position
even compete beyond what we're doing now
resilient diverse and secure supply
chains
are going to help revitalize our
domestic manufacturing capacity
and create good paying jobs not fifteen
dollars an hour which is we need to do
some day
and as soon as a better in my view but
jobs that are at the prevailing wage
we're going to spare new ups
spur new opportunities for small
businesses communities of color and
economically distressed areas
and i will drive new investment in
research and innovation
and our workforce investing in training
in university partnerships that are
going to lead to new technologies and
new solutions
and all this won't just strengthen our
domestic capacity
will help unleash new markets around the
world
and grow opportunities for american
business to export
their goods that we're going to be
making these are the kinds of common
sense solutions that all americans can
get behind
workers and corporate leaders
republicans and democrats
it's about resilience identifying
possible points of vulnerabilities in
our supply
chains and making sure we have the
backup alternatives
or work arounds in place remember that
old proverb
for want of a nail the shoe was lost for
want of a shoe the horse was lost
and it goes on and on until the kingdom
was lost
all for the want of a horseshoe nail
even small failures at one point in the
supply chain can cause outside
impacts further up the chain recently
we've seen
how shortage of computer chips computer
chips
like the one i have here you can hardly
see it i imagine
it's called a semiconductor it's caused
delays and production of automobiles
as a result of reduced hours for
american workers
a 21st century horseshoe nail
this semiconductor is smaller than the
postage stamp but it has more than
8 billion transistors eight
billion transistors ten thousand times
thinner
than a single human hair in this one
chip
these chips are a wonder of innovation
design
the power so much of our country enables
so much of our modern lives to
go on not just our cars but our
smartphones televisions
radios medical diagnostic equipment and
so much more
we need to make sure these supply chains
are secure and reliable
i'm directing senior officials in my
administration to work with industrial
leaders to identify solutions
to this semiconductor shortfall and work
very hard
with the house and senate they've
authorized the bill
but they need very 37 billion dollars
short term
to make sure we have this capacity we'll
push for that as well but we all
recognize
that the particular problem won't be
solved immediately in the meantime we're
reaching out to our allies
semiconductor companies and others in
the supply chain to ramp up production
to help us resolve the bottlenecks we
face now
we need help to stop we need to stop
playing catch-up
after the supply chain crisis hit we
need to prevent
the supply stand crisis from hitting in
the first place
and in some cases building resilience
will mean
increasing our production of certain
types of elements
here at home and others will be working
more closely with our trusted friends
and partners
nations that share our values so that
our supply chains can't be used against
us as leverage
it will mean identifying and building
surge capacity that can quickly be
turned into
and ramped up production in times of
emergency
and it will mean investing in research
and development
like we did in the 60s to ensure
long-term conver competitiveness in our
manufacturing base
in the decades ahead the order i'm about
to sign just two things
first it orders a 100-day review
of four vital products semiconductors
one key minerals and materials like
rare earths that are used to make
everything from
harder steel to airplanes three
pharmaceuticals and their ingredients
four advanced batteries like the one
jews and electric vehicles
there's strong bipartisan support for
fast reviews of these four areas because
they're essential to protecting and
strengthening american competitiveness
second this order initiates a long-term
review
of the industry basis of six sectors of
our
overall economy over the next year these
reviews will identify policy
recommendations
to 40 of our supply chain should be to
fortify our supply chains
at every step and critically to start
implementing those recommendations
right away we're not going to wait for
you to be completed before we start
closing the existing gaps
and as we implement this work my
administration will draw on a full range
of american talent
including labor and industry leaders
policy experts
scientists farmers engineers to get
their input
i'm grateful for the members of congress
who came to see me
republican leaders as well as democrats
they're leading the way
we're going to stay in close contact
with members of both sides of the aisle
and keep advancing our shared goals
everyone has a role to play to
strengthen our supply chains in our and
our country
this is the united states of america we
are better prepared
to meet the challenges of the 21st
century than any
country in the world there's nothing
nothing nothing we've ever failed
achieved if we work together
that's what we decided to do today and
that's what we're going to do
work together so i thank you all i'm
very optimistic about the meeting we had
today with our congressional colleagues
and now i'm going to walk over and
sign that executive order
thank you very that more of your much
nominees have not yet been confirmed by
the senate
i am but i don't so much blame it
from the senate i blame it on the
failure to have a transition that was
rational
as you know previous administrations had
a significant number of their
uh their cabinet uh confirmed
before they even were sworn in that's
the tradition
but we're doing fine i think we're gonna
be in good shape what
thank you